to become obtain pistols you need to
just declare very simply that you
support LGBT people for legally
obtaining legal firearms for
self-defense
including concealed carry I'm a pacifist
by nature I personally am a big believer
in developing skills to maintain my own
safety I am NOT currently thinking about
buying one or or becoming a gun advocate
but I do believe in just being skilled
and using this tool
unlike a normal self-defence where a
person can negotiate because they're
being wronged the perpetrators so
purposes hate and their sole purpose is
to kill you or hurt you very much
your only choice is really to run away
surrender usually means that
you